[Music]
well hi if there's one thing Disney is
good at its seeking a gloomy fairy tale
and turning it into a classic animated
film but some Disney plots don't always
add up causing viewers to come up with
some dark explanations of their own
these Disney theories are so morbid
they'll slip your childhood on its head
watch until the end to find out which
young hero is predicted to be the most
ruthless from Reaper in Disney history
seems we have time the prince
there's something about Snow White in
the Seven Dwarves that has never sat
well with viewers
first of all Snow White was only 14
years old when she married the prince
second of all snows crazy stepmother
literally tried to end her life going as
far as to ask the Huntsman to carve out
her heart and put it in a box Snow
White's story seems to end on a high
note she marries the prince and lives
happily ever after but according to a
redditor named cherries aid that's not
exactly how things went down according
to their dark theory the prince is
actually death personified in this
theory Snow White truly passes away
after eating the poisonous Apple then
the Prince aka the Grim Reaper gives
Snow the kiss of death and takes her to
the afterlife taking things a step
further the pale horse that the couple
rides away on is said to be a biblical
metaphor
once again symbolizing the afterlife
this theory changes everything but
believe it or not the prince isn't the
only grim reaper in this video and he's
certainly not the scariest King Triton's
role the daughter of the Great Sea King
is a very precious commodity
this next Disney theory brings us to the
depths of the Atlantic Ocean where king
triton rolls over atlanta qey a scene in
The Little Mermaid
despite having seven daughters all of
which are more responsible than Ariel
Triton always had a soft spot for the
young
his daughter but there's a dark theory
surrounding Triton's large family and
gene pool this theory accuses triton of
infidelity amongst many other things
first of all have you ever noticed that
every single one of ariel sisters looks
completely different well this might be
because there are only half sisters it's
believed that to further his bloodline
king triton never has two children with
the same mermaid he chooses to keep his
daughters and raises them to be
showpieces like he wanted to do with
Ariel another theory suggests that King
Triton does not want to have any sons
because they could try and take his
throne away so he makes sure his wives
only supply him with daughters if you
know what we mean but this terrifying
theory doesn't end there it's believed
that Triton actually gets rid of his
wives after they give him a daughter
then he marries someone new and repeats
the deadly cycle Carl's last snapped
this next theory is so dark and twisted
it can be hard to accept but it's also
beautiful in its own special way
indices up we mean an old widow who is
tired of being pushed around by the
developers in his neighborhood they want
to tear down his house to build
something new and Carl's against it I
believe I made my position here boss
quite clear sadly there's little Carl
can do there's a reddit theory that
suggests that Carl actually passes away
in his armchair after the developers
tell him to vacate his residence
Carl's journey to the mountains is
considered to be his journey to heaven
but before he can truly be reunited with
his loved one he needs to do a good deed
so he serves as Russell's guardian angel
and helps him earn his assisting the
elderly badge for assisting the elderly
[Music]
the more we think about this theory the
more it makes sense
however if this theory is true up would
resemble the short film above than
beyond to a tee and to see would be
accused of feeling Yannick vent arrows
idea once again but this time they'd
have trouble dismissing the rumors
Gaston the hunter Gaston from Beauty and
the Beast is one of the most
self-centered individuals in Disney
history he's so confident he borders on
delusional
although Gaston does Farish at the end
of the movie there's a theory that laces
him in another Disney flick before the
events of Beauty and the Beast take
place during the song Gaston Gaston
sings about hunting he says that when he
hunts he sneaks up on his prey he also
says that he always aims for the liver
and shoots from behind after a while
Disney fans began to wonder if Gaston
could be the hunter who shot bandies
mother and the more they dug around the
more clues they seemed to find at the
beginning of the movie before Prince
Adam gets curse you can see a deer
peacefully eating grass in the forest
redditors believe this to be Bambi's
mother as well as an easter egg at the
end of the song Gaston says that he uses
antlers in all of his decorating once
again proving that he has hunted deers
in the past Cusco and the fly
then there's the dark theory surrounding
the hilarious movie The Emperor's New
Groove we're all familiar with how used
my chose to betray Cusco and she
attempted to usurp his throne a toast to
the Emperor
long live Cusco however instead of
ending his life like she had planned to
scope gets turned into a llama and runs
away into the jungle but there's a
theory that Cusco isn't the first human
to be transformed into an animal or
insect in fact according to some viewers
who posted on reddit we even see
these transformed humans midway through
the animated film in Islam afore Moscow
is still able to speak to humans but he
cannot speak to other animals however in
one particularly morbid scene Cusco sees
a fly get trapped in a spider's web the
flight begs Cusco for his help and Cusco
can understand him as though he was a
human himself sadly he met a very
gruesome end
Cinderella's stepfamily Cinderella did
not have an easy life and things got
even more complicated when her father
remarried and brought an evil stepmother
and two mischievous stepsisters into the
mix the Disney movie Cinderella has more
than a few dark secrets at its core some
of these theories have been cooked up by
fans and others have been present since
the original fairy tale was written
either way fans believe that Cinderella
wanted revenge on her set family after
she married Prince Charming and
eventually became Queen in the original
fairy tale Cinderella uses brute force
to end her stepmothers life then she
sticks her Birds on her stepsisters
making them lose their eyesight well
this does not happen in the Disney
version dedicated Disney fans think that
Cinderella's step family still got what
they deserved after the first movie be
it from starvation poverty or sickness
that is if we don't take the sequel into
account there's also a theory that Lady
Tremaine is the one who killed sundar
Ella's father as she had once done with
Anastasia and Drizella as dad Christophe
secret this next theory is so disturbing
it might have the power to ruin the bond
between Kristoff and Sven the frozen
franchise is dark enough as it is but
this theory is the cherry on top we all
know that Kristoff grew up in an
orphanage alongside his best friends
before moving in with the trolls
Kristoff hung out with the ice
harvesters and helped them when he could
fans believe that Kristoff and Sven
became friends after spends mother was
hunted by the ice harvesters who then
used her Pelt to create an outfit for
Kristoff if you look at Christoph's
outfit you'll see that he's wearing some
sort of leather the fur on the trim of
his sleeves resembles fence fur making
viewers think that Kristoff is wearing
spends mother's pelts span and Kristoff
must have been way too young to remember
the events that brought them together
but deep down we think Kristoff must
know the truth Pleasure Island Pinocchio
is by far one of the most disturbing
Disney movies of all time this animated
film has so many theories attached to it
we don't know where to start there's the
theory that Geppetto is a senile old man
who is so lonely he carves himself a son
out of the piece of wood nokia might be
rethought
however the fairies never come to give
Pinocchio life but Geppetto imagines
this and pretends that his son is a real
boy this theory is pretty sad but it
pales in comparison to this next one
viewers also believe that Geppetto once
had a son who disappeared causing him to
go insane just like Pinocchio his son
was taken to Pleasure Island by mr.
Honest John in the Pleasure Island scene
we see that the coachman caused the kids
stupid little boys before putting them
in cages and saying they never come back
as boys Geppetto could have created a
replica of his first son and dreamed up
the entire movie however this time
around his son came home and was still a
real boy Nemo isn't real Finding Nemo is
an amazing movie that teaches us the
importance of family and letting go
be safe but just like Pinocchio there's
something about the film that doesn't
sit well with viewers some dark theories
state that Merlin never had a son named
Nemo the grief-stricken clownfish was so
devastated when his wife and baby eggs
were taken from him is my tricked him
into believing that one single egg
remained Merlin was so distraught that
he raised the imaginary Nemo
until one day Nemo disappeared while on
his way to school funny enough the name
Nemo can be translated to no one or no
man in Latin the child Reaper
shed the more we watched Disney's Peter
Pan the more disturbing it becomes as
children it's easy to get lost in this
story and imagine ourselves soaring
through the air with Peter but as adults
we can't help but make the connection
between Peter Pan and the brim Reaper
Disney's Peter Pan took place around the
same time as world war two bomb shelters
and attacks are mentioned throughout the
franchise there's a theory that suggests
that the darling family passed away on
the same night that Peter came to take
the children this theory states that
Peter is the grim reaper responsible for
collecting the souls of children he
stays hidden in kit form to make the
children he collects feel more
comfortable he then brings them to
Neverland where their souls can rest and
never age as for Captain Hook some
believe that hopes child was taken by
Peter which made him go mad with hatred
for him which one of these dizzy
theories hit you the hardest sound off
in the comments thanks for watching the
scene be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more we'll catch you later
[Music]